طيب المؤخرا خلونا نروح الى العراق وهناك
عاد الحديث عن اقدم نكته مسجله في التاريخ
وهي تنسب للسومريين يعني للعراقيين في
يومنا الحالي اقدم نكته خليني اخبرك هادي
شويه نكته
يعود تاريخها الى حوالي 4000 عام قبل
الميلاد تقول كلب يدخل الى حانه يقول لا
استطيع رؤيه شيء هل يجب ان افتح واحده
[موسيقى]
يعني التنكيت ودم الخفيف معايير مختلفه
خلينا نقول بانه يعني نبتعد كيفهم بايخه
حلوه ايام نكت قبل نكهته لا تبدون مضحكه
ربما وليست مفهومه مش مثل نكت العراقيين
في الوقت الحالي لكن المستخدمين حاولوا فك
شفرتها يعني بالفعل تحاولوا واجتهدوا احد
تفسيرات انه الحيوانات ربما كانت منتشره
جدا لدرجه ان بعضها كان فارغا وحتى الكلب
يستطيع ان يفتح انا هذا والله كثير منطقي
لكن بعض المختصين يعتقدون ان النكته كانت
تحتوي على لغز لا نفهمه الان علاقه
بالسياق الزمني وعادات اهل او عادات
السومريين
اعتمادوا بعد اكثر من 6000 سنه صعب
انك تدفنين تدفلين الشيء وما تقولين على
كل حال بما انه صباح العربي هو صباح
السعاده دائما طلبنا من الناس في السعوديه
ان يروا لنا نكته
قديمه ايش طلعوا وياهم خلينا نشوف
[موسيقى]
طيب يقول لك مره في واحد يبغى عنده سياره
قديمه ويبغى يبيعها ومنو عارف وما حد قاعد
يشتريها سال صاحبه القديمه قال له بسيطه
حط علامه مرسيدس على السياره وهي تنباع
قام قال له بعد اسبوع شاف السياره معه ليش
ما بعتها قال له انت تستهبل في احد يبيع
مرسيدس
ههه يقول واحد باله طويل راح الخياط
يقول لك هيل قال نمله فوق ظهري يبي يطير
من السوق لما الفيل الرقه فوق ظهر النمله
ما جاني شيء لما قالت انا دوري انا اللي
برقد فوق ظهر الفيل ومات انكس بس كنا نضحك
عليها على اساس انه تناسب عقليتها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات